[Musique]
mon père était stagiaire comme si quelque chose de mal
se produisait si la maison de quelqu'un prenait
feu alors si c'était un accident il les
aiderait à récupérer leur heureuse femme à
nouveau une configuration assez douce vous avez
tout le monde comme des enfants tous neuf mètres
Rêve américain
[Musique]
désolé monsieur  Scanlan mais nous avons besoin du
paiement à l'avance pourquoi ne me donnez-vous pas
une [ __ ] de pause
calmez-vous nous parlons de ma famille
[ __ ] de réalités que whoa merde
nous avons inventé Dieu nous arrête l'un à l'autre la
mort s'effondrera pas un animal je connais
la différence  entre le bien et le mal tu
sais nous voulons faire ce qui détruit ta
famille alors nous voulons
la pluie pas de péché pluie pas de vertu c'était
juste